Comcast this production company
continues to be a bit of hilarious irony
look I know this is London and I've
never been there
I mostly know this from star trek into
darkness and that one Fantastic Four
movie my point is the average person
knows this is London without being told
so why are we being told I said if you
want to glimpse the future guy talking
to himself basically disguises that this
is opening narration but you bet your
bloody Yankee whimper nuts that this is
narration or however British people
express it know the kids first of all
that this asshole somehow survived that
the last movie second of all talking to
an obviously comatose person third of
all sudden even more badass brother
villain his sudden yeah but shouldn't
there still be a doesn't SWAT teams
waiting for him once he reaches the main
floor yep Lily would have you believe
you can do this much damage to a place
and then walk out a sub place several
minutes later with no cops haven't shown
up by the way what kind of asshole
hospital building waits until you're
outside before collapsing parts of its
ilk and somehow all the destruction
managed to avoid hitting this new
villains precious white sports car it
took four editors to edit this bull and
do to photograph it friends when you
start seeing the star of the movie serve
as a producer it's just like those TV
shows that have gone too long and they
start getting the cast unnecessary
credits to make them feel like they're
people from the creator of the Saw
franchise which is a good fit for the
series that is devolved into the car
version of torture porn anyway this an
open road helps you think I thought it
shuts down during crime sleep how
worried then where are you going they do
not say that race was someone needs to
rename this event quickly whoa when did
dirt bikes get invited to girls well
guess it's important to let everyone
know just how much you respect women
thankfully amidst all this female
showering they remember to actually hold
some car races this girl's ass
apparently just signed a seven picture
deal at Universal because it was
featured at least 15 times during this
pre-race action also I thought this crew
was all about heists now not car racing
judging by the last several movies they
should give two shits about race Wars
Iggy Azalea isn't not in the scene Dom
allows Hector to touch him with his
hands which were just a minute ago
wiping off bloody mouth fluids
this is supposed to be funny
but he was the door button uh didn't you
use the door button when you left this
morning
or did Jordana Brewster do it for you
you're telling me a gearhead like this
guy can't figure out where the button is
just because he's driving a minivan
Bryan just lets this chick take his kid
assuming she works here which thankfully
for him she does but Jesus right here
take my kid I've got a crime to commit
character knows exactly where other
character is because character knows
other character so will cliche lady get
steep by staring at her own fake
gravestone that's the date that I lost
my memory Jesus skip I have to find
myself for me Letty he breaks up with
Dom at her own grave while he's holding
a sledgehammer and somehow no one
thought to walk out of the theater right
at this moment camera dollies away from
a dude wielding a sledgehammer he was
going to use to destroy the headstone of
a sex girl friend who's not dead cliche
Deckard is apparently so good he can
sneak into this place without anybody
noticing
which is the skill I guess you developed
because your brothers in a coma and you
really want revenge for it I see you
better start talking before I break that
finger six different ways why are you
doing that already you just earned
yourself a dance with the devil boy that
like like I said I mean for the team
that crippled my brother you didn't say
anything about your crippled brother
until this statement these guys have hit
each other in a faced way too many times
for neither of them to be bleeding
profusely I guess I should be excited
about seeing the rock and Jason Statham
getting in a fight but I just can't help
but think the rock should win this
easily also Rock Stock and Two Smoking
Barrels Deckard survives this probably
because that table he kicked out in
front of him was so sturdy and Hobbs and
Elena survived this because you don't
care anyway barely we're still not past
Tokyo Drift yet in this series despite
the fact that we saw Deckard finish Han
off at the end of the last movie so he
basically just saw a 15-minute prequel
to the end of Fast & Furious 6 which is
chronologically the fifth movie in the
seventh movie of the series another baby
he didn't tell did you telling your
brother this before your husband I don't
want him to be disappointed with his
life this is the flimsiest of all movie
romance obstacles she's lying to her
beloved husband because she thinks he
misses the action and crime of his old
life so much he can't possibly take the
news of yet another kid you got nothing
you're about to Dom decides you know
what that box that came from huh
probably a bomb sent by this mysterious
voice on the phone coming from Tokyo
because what else could it be also the
fact that Deckard gives any warning
before the box explodes this bomb blows
up the entire house but somehow it
doesn't harm DOM and his sister who were
standing right outside the house yeah
also despite the considerable force that
ran Brian's face into the window and
nearly broke through it his face his ass
pristine is when he was born in diesel
is wondering where his sledgehammer is
for the shop also to Deckard set that
bomb up knowing it would fail he's on
this oddly personal vendetta but he
tries to kill Tom Brian and Mia with
remote-controlled bomb which might be
the dumbest movie bomb in history
shudder his collarbone fractured his leg
in two places
I know getting exploded out of a window
and falling ten stories into your car
you think that would taste like cupcakes
but Hobbs was really unlucky when the
rock suffers he suffers sex-linked you
risk life and limb to save the free
world and where do they give you jello
and a bad 70s TV show did you not see
the gun though I also gave him a big
guy's gun also that show ruled so shut
your whore mouth you remember Owen Shaw
the one we tore half of London down
shining good nope was that the last
movie wasn't it Karl Urban or somebody
from Lord of the hobbit' that was that
bad guy I get my fast and drive angries
mixed up hey how do we make the rock a
star of this movie while still letting
him honors WWE contract easy injure him
early on and have him show back up for
the finale brilliant this is a lot of
dramatic camera movement for what is a
simple phone call especially for this
series just promise me after this we're
done
she says this roughly five years in five
movies too late in case you confused it
with Tokyo Equatorial Guinea hey look in
Tokyo they also have unreasonably short
skirts at car gatherings we're not
really so different after all
hey yo saw movie saves money by actually
playing the end of Tokyo Drift and
cutting some apalis lines also they cut
out the part where bow-wow told Shawn
about Dom beating everybody all over
Asia because clearly that's not why dog
came out here han said you was fast but
not that damn fast okay first of all did
you bring your American muscle car to
Japan cuz that had to take in weeks
second of all is the race over
did you guys race and show us none of it
we found a couple things about a crash
you did were you driving around when
Deckard killed him how did you get your
hands on crash site memorabilia when you
find the guy that killed Han what are
you going to woods and you've been in
Jesus working for a real treat when
Deckard gets killed because we've been
promised twice it's going to be
something the English language has
trouble translating they say to live in
the hearts of those would be upon I
thought it shuts down during cryo sleep
a candle no more funerals
but how else you can earn that paycheck
tyrese first Han now Hobbs is laid up
rocky that line makes no sense just
he'll died first then haunt and Hobbes
is Mary hurt so he does not belong in
this train of thought you just began
Thomas Mowbray almost uncapable promise
peace also the sad irony is thick and
uncomfortable yeah zoom that film out to
make a look faster Tyree I mean for
editors who did this movie now we know
why Kurt Russell is in this movie
because these cars are definitely death
Proof so there's got to be a street
fight sudden SWAT ex machina has the
element of surprise and they still miss
Decker
whoa Corona man myself we already knew
that because we've seen the previous six
movies but still super obvious dialogue
based product placement its ass
say hello to God's eye fast and furious
takes Lucius Fox is soon our concept
that applies it to this movie this is
wrong any rescue plans involving any US
government forces or entity has been
strictly ruled out yeah but foreign
governments would rightfully blame the
US anyway if they saw a bunch of drag
race and Americans insert themselves
into this situation so why not use
somebody in the world who's less
criminal than dominus group I mean I
could go back outside enjoy the rest of
the Coronas Corona Corona Corona Corona
Corona ah a Corona let's all come to me
you could do that how's that working out
for you so far it's working out no
different from every other Fast &
Furious movie but Dom decides to help
mr. nobody because Deckard's been
slightly more successful than the other
bad guys in this series which is why
I've taken the liberty of gathering your
team
right on cue and straight from Hans
funeral also none of them needed the
factual persuading you did apparently it
all just came with my agents without
incident amazing no this is crazy
paycheck diaries movie steals that
stupid bull from a team it makes it even
more stupid Bulls beer I thought it let
you down what okay so now the parachute
is already deployed miles up in the sky
attached to a fucking car and somehow
Tyrese is gonna survive this we're
supposed to be concerned that anybody
can die in this that's why they've been
talking funerals so much but I'm not
really all that worried and that's a
problem they've never done this before
but they're going to land perfectly in
the drop zone as if it's routine so
Tiger omen will come back here come back
for him
why did you even shoot him out of the
plane if you don't need him in the first
place alright you got one chance to hit
him here Dom
you missed them make it to their black
site unnecessary orders
sooo I wasn't here already ahead of them
did they really think they were sneaking
up on these guys bulletproof baby
carriages I'll overlook the casual MC
Hammer reference and instead say if this
vehicle is bulletproof how did the other
car survive the bullets then not that I
buy any of the book these movies have
shown me but these movies have shown me
this group being very detailed in their
planning to the point that these
surprise guns should not be a surprise
its armor-piercing where Ryan Scion was
able to withstand hundreds of
armor-piercing rounds the look I know
the series gets off on showing us not
believable stuff but this is well beyond
that into the realm of few footage also
it's worth noting you don't even need
armor-piercing bullets if you shoot at
the tires watch the road
Ryan tez blow it let's split up the
detonators from the cars firing the
bombs because there's no chance any
other four cars will get taken out
before this point the battle that was
easy cheek with guy's name is a chick
cliche I guess the bad guy who's driving
this bus is completely oblivious to all
the stuff that just happened in the back
of it probably has headphones on like
all people who miss things in movies do
what go ah the old trip where you throw
a woman onto a speeding car before she's
ready for it and then she loses her grip
and has never done this before but
somehow stays in the car how does this
asshole know anything about that how is
he here how is she screaming when she's
clearly dead guy with plenty of guns at
his disposal decides to do this Paul
Walker versus Tony Jaa you didn't know
you wanted it but you got it this should
be a pretty easy fight I'd say but
somehow Brian's going to hold his own
when is she even holding on to also I'm
genuinely convinced at this point this
franchise is actively trying to create
more work for us
maybe the villains tank buggy will be
fine but this vehicle down driving is
not going downhill off-road in a forest
without a fire accident this all these
street vehicles driving down a
mountainside scene is way more Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles than I think the
movie's intended barely also she
probably had better odds to survive
longer back in the villains custody if
we're being honest even GTA 5 won't let
you drive a vehicle down Mount chiliad
without dying for sake
stunt jump fail just because you decide
to make this slow motion doesn't mean
they should survive this fall but screw
it what do I know this is the most
critically acclaimed episode in the
series I would have removed 100 sins if
that happened to be ladies car instead
of the bad guys also same gun that hit
Brian's car a thousand times will now
flip a villain car off the cliff in
three seconds the bus driver is in plain
view of all this stuff going on in the
back why did he even keep driving after
Brian say Bram Z dead driver somehow
manages to keep this bus on the road you
know how hard shuffleboard and paper
football is in the movies they can score
maximum points every time with large
vehicles this movie is so very tiring
this is an ex machina how the fuck did
he know they were here moment and a
paycheque scene all rolled into one
lost world Jurassic Park Brian moment is
still pretty lost world Jurassic Park
everyone who loves these movies
basically just loves cartoons that's
okay as long as you can admit okay so
where the hell was she this whole time
and how is she able to accurately assess
that Brian is running up the bus when
she can't even see him also I guess tej
is hanging out somewhere with his
bulletproof SUV in ex machina mode
waiting to pounce on a situation that
needs ex machina ng Oh No
whatever will he do to get out of this
situation I'm so heartbroken right now
how could you I feel bad for this guy
he's fantastic but aside from Amistad
and Blood Diamond has been typecast as
token action henchman in everything from
the island to push to guardians of the
galaxy to this farce of a movie what's
again today legit having not seen this
film until now I'm betting he still
drives off the clip and somehow survives
fire on my mom on your mark why not just
shoot now because no one cares this is
allowed to happen even in a movie and
people are like thrilling let's go give
this movie a billion dollars worldwide I
love it when there are no consequences
whatsoever if these assholes could make
it down to the crash site in time then
surely give us fries henchmen could have
it's like I mean I just what do you even
what's more DOM isn't even hurt I don't
care what kind of reinforced bull
vehicle they made he doesn't even have a
scar we were worried about funerals in
this movie for some reason I mailed it
to a friend in Abu Dhabi movie rips off
Garfield's favorite place to ship OD how
you took help who guys she's training
yeah but you had a hood on during all
that so how did you see his techniques
we're going to the Middle East you're in
Azerbaijan you're like basically already
in the Middle East go few miles south
and you're in thing
ran dude do you even map meanwhile very
close to our last location discount tube
on this side shot makes it look like
they all pulled up in order like this
but then this wide front shot shows how
impossible basically any of those timed
injuries were due to you know all that
behind them before we've seen one hacker
skill the sexy ramsey is in a bikini
getting agha like to feel superior by
saying liberal douche stuff even though
i'm secretly enjoying this but damn
can't we see her at her job first before
we see this I have to call dibs on
Ramsey two years ago who are you and how
did you know what they were talking
about I need the speed drive I said me
where is it I sold it why would you sell
it oh because of the cinematic adventure
I get it now why in the hell would he
keep his car in his penthouse he's a
billionaire my friend he can do whatever
he wants
plus we needed some reason for that
stupid stunt that's gonna happen later
so we'll blame it on the crazy
billionaire now why in the hell would he
keep his car in his penthouse
despite swapping the word why into the
question in place of how ludicrous would
be excellent at cinemasins I think i'ma
start a new culture called Lera you know
like black Arab that's racist I got a
move in sync if we're gonna pull this
off so let's go over to make sure
everyone clearly understands their roles
yeah let's go over the plan during the
plan instead of beforehand brilliant
yeah a whole plane ride thank god this
paranoid billionaire middle-east Prince
doesn't believe in video surveillance
Emory what about my steps what am I
supposed to be doing it's kind of like
the series realized that Roman was the
Hawkeye of the group and started making
jokes about it guess what
just like age of Ultron making jokes
doesn't redeem his character at all as I
stare at these two female asses which
the camera dictates I do I have to
wonder do I have time to masturbate
before anything important happens on
screen every King guard gets distracted
by Romans Happy Birthday ruse
I guess Michelle Rodriguez is always
going to be tasked to fight some female
MMA star in these movies we're pretty
sure she could beat up most guys but got
to keep those showdown strictly double X
none of these soldiers use guns
by the way wearing ladies training was
she able to take on three experienced
fighters all at once she had her hands
full with gina carano last movie it took
forever for these guards to finally say
enough Tsin up and stop roman from doing
whatever he was doing tonight the part
of Holly Holmes we played by Michelle
Rodriguez movie pretends that fall in
any way hurt these two women by fast and
furious rules they should have actually
gotten stronger by crashing into the DJ
station but all those in the final gate
you got to get out of it you're losing
the final gate first of all how do you
even have control over this gate
second of all why is one of the gate
sturdier than all the other gates that
fell down at the same time a minute ago
Ludi gives tez even more badassery way
before they consider giving Roman
anything worthwhile at all extremely
fragile sports car blasts through the
bolt wall and gets no damage I realize
this is the bad guy of this movie but I
have no idea how or why he's here right
now actually I'm not even sure why our
heroes are here right now I think the
movie just hopes to blind me to the
nonsensical storyline with crazy action
there are more bulletproof cars in this
movie than there are human actors
instead of just running over Deckard
with this car Tom decides yeah I can
make this car crash through the window
and fly over to the other building that
makes way more sense I think yeah I'm
adding a thousand sins for this 1000
most critically acclaimed movie in the
series also at this point this would be
considered a terror attack and there
would be thousands of soldiers police
and government agencies swarming this
place by the time they get downstairs
also how many windows that they crash
through at high impact
a spectacular stunt should have some
element of danger but it shouldn't be
impossible I mean how lucky are these
dicks that they didn't hit this building
between floors or like on a support beam
or something
also why isn't Optimus helping them
during the battle people doing normal
stuff don't see the crazy falling from
the sky outside cliche they still would
have been okay movie will now gloss over
how nobody arrests them for this and
even Decker doesn't go down to the
ground to figure out where the hell they
went next or wait for them anywhere also
if this movie thinks those two stunts
are as cool as it thinks it is they
missed a golden opportunity to show in
one shot all three buildings with all
five holes cut through them my guys are
racist best drivers in the world but
they ain't killers how you even seen any
of the previous movies I hope you're
enjoying your last meal before prison he
meant to say last meal before prison
right because you didn't come here
specifically to assassinate this guy did
you
none of these guys shoot this asshole
right now for some reason redness
darkness gunfire Bulls good thing he
gave everyone a pair of those night
vision sunglasses and glasses advantage
lasts all of 15 seconds awesome okay so
why did they bring the gods I hear they
knew where Deckard was they could have
simply left this back at the garage and
Letty Ramsey tej Roman could have
radioed in any movements but now it's
here so the bad guy can happen and I
can't think of anything more critically
acclaimed than that grenade thrown by
Shaw seems to basically only hinder
Shaw's meant the whole war is coming
we're gonna face him on the streets we
know best
Piccadilly Circus the US Mexican border
you guys have had so many adventures I'm
honestly not sure what you're talking
about here I guess maybe LA but then
that was mostly just the first movie so
I give up
I don't know dice I brought you here
today to show you Los Angeles it has
nothing to do with what we need to do
but I get this weird feeling people are
watching us I need to know where we are
also we're going to discuss our plan
here even though we had 16 hours of
flight between Abu Dhabi and LA to work
it out if they use God's eye it'll tap
the cameras around town and find our
location it's concise supposed to be
Jason Statham because this guy meant it
just to find wherever these people are
even without a contact we can't start a
hack on him until they're within a
two-mile range oh I don't know about
y'all but I didn't really plan on dying
today the completion of that sentence
required me to look at my watch
obviously we're gonna have another baby
Jesus Steve now see why you might have
told him this earlier okay just jack for
me well me it really got screwed in this
movie she might as well be an answering
machine of course the entire house was
destroyed by fire except the garage and
the classic dad remembered scar good
guys and bad guys both head out from
their lairs at the same time almost as
though this climax was scheduled oh no
we're being hacked and we're in an
attack helicopter
I know send in the automated drones so a
few things here luckily Brian and Ramsey
are right next to one of those rigs
where a car can fit underneath but also
everyone on this street stops and moves
to the side of the road except the rig
they need to drive under and then when
the main action starts up suddenly no
one cares about the drone and they're
all going for a merry Drive like nothing
major is happening and what happened all
the people who stopped in the middle of
the road they vanished oh now you notice
something crazy going on in this town
the cops here have less reaction time
than the Grand Theft Auto cops a second
game of chicken in a movie is an
immediate sin in fact it's another
hundred yes Brian is running this red
light because climactic reasons but why
is the light blue Prius in the next lane
over also running the solid red light
and the SUV on the opposite lane
I mean seriously all we're asking is
just once where one of these things does
not work and the person doing the stupid
thing dies I could accept loads of bull
there were more hero deaths in these
situations in fact I'd be the first to
say bullshit enchilada supreme please
with extra bull
he jumped but he's also dead I look
forward to this movie explaining to me
why he isn't dead the military still
hasn't made it to Los Angeles yet so
drawl oh the rock is in this movie I
totally forgot mostly because he's
basically making a cameo - Rhett oh yes
some crazy explosion happens and it must
be Toretto
you glad no one was driving down this
road in downtown LA less believable than
him flexing off his cast is the fact
that he's got all the military gear in
the world in his hospital room hero
tosses weapon to settle things with
fisticuffs cliche yung shue him dude
Jesus we've been waiting for this for so
long
Letty the footballs on fire we need help
seriously what the been doing this whole
time
she's just back up isn't she way more
badass than this to be driving around as
a backup James Wan definitely thinks
these camera movements all through the
movie when people are falling down are
exciting they are not this whole movie
could have been about Tony John and I
would have loved it instead the guy
basically has a glorified cameo in the
movie another expendable it's amazing
when these guys are getting their brains
beat in they suddenly have the clarity
to arrange an almost Rube Goldberg like
escape oh yeah the rock is in this movie
so now this missiles direct hit does not
destroy or even incapacitate the car ah
how does this guy know where to go and
what the situation is in order to make
this crash of faith this could be the
luckiest thing I've ever seen in this
series and I'm still spinning from that
Dom becomes Superman to see if Letty
scene in fast 6 la hey lady you woman ha
I have the Calvary who is that
well based on this movie alone The
Terminator Plus got shove in the weight
and it seems our friendship is I demand
why does Gioconda give two shits about
Toretto this whole time he cared about
the gods i and killing ramsey but now he
allows the killing of Deckard because he
suddenly needs to kill Toretto all while
the military is three minutes away thing
about street fights the street always
wins
you're on a rule how did Dom not only
know that stomping would open a new toll
but also that it would open perfectly to
swallow Shawn but leave Dom himself
right on the edge goodbye
we have such a crazy history together
Homs is trying to be helpful
but it's taking his ass forever to shoot
down this chopper another impossible
survival but for those of you who
enjoyed this movie what's it like being
in the matrix ignorance is bliss right
okay
Dom you're in a fast and furious movie
where the thing that is a million-to-one
actually has way better odds like even
money stop acting like there's any
difficulty here when critics love this
to the point that it's rotten tomatos
score is 81% are they really loving it
or are they worried the younger
generation will accuse them of being out
of touch letting just he survived it
okay Oh from way down here on the ground
Homs just knew that bag was full of
grenades that's some ridiculous
intuition right there this is some
Shazam black atom test footage that
somehow made its way into this film's
final cut I'm really gonna go through
this Dom might have died nonsense what a
waste of time let he finally remembering
is what somehow makes Dom come back to
life in movies man they take and they
ping tape dude by the way I'm still
pissed the military hasn't shown up yet
why didn't you tell me we were married
because he didn't know about it until
now the screenwriter went back in time
put this in there so there'd be
something emotional to revive it so this
is news to him as well
yep he survived that parking garage
collapse just fun dude though okay
sure four Furious 8 you'll have the
x-men come and save you with the help of
Quicksilver but he might be considered
dead in one franchise and not dead in
another anyway enjoy your escape when
the US government gets compromised it's
a waste of time to lock his ass up
and I thought Donna Hobbs were gonna do
something so bad to him the English
language needed to invent new words
obviously not Paul Walker shot what it's
not too soon right that was over a year
ago and this is pretty obvious no Paul
Walker tribute doesn't include his
performances in running scared varsity
blues Joyride into the blue and Apollo
I wanted a what a lovely day